Sergueï aujourd'hui pourquoi vous êtes
plus inquiet que jamais parce que c'est
une escalade encore une escalade donc
d'abord il y a eu samedi cette
attentation le pont c'est pas un jour
comme un autre parce que vendredi
c'était
70e anniversaire de Poutine mais donc
bien évidemment tout le monde se disait
comment il va péter comment elle va
fêter cette fête et qu'est-ce que les
Ukrainiens vont lui offrir comme pour
fêter donc il y a déjà le comité de prix
Nobel qui lui a offert un joli prix
Nobel de la paix qui est attribué à à
défenseur des droits de l'homme
biélorusses à une organisation
ukrainienne et une organisation russe et
donc en fait on se disait ça allait se
passer c'est bien et puis on est
réveillé samedi matin à 6h du matin avec
le pont qui brûle donc en fait il y a 7
citerne avec le carburant qui brûle et
un camion qui a sauté donc tout de suite
il y a il y a les vidéos qui pas à
circuler et il faudrait que vous
compreniez ce que c'est que ce pont donc
la Crimée est un excès en 2014 et la
Crimée était donc c'est une péninsule 3
parties la mer autour et quatrième
partie fermée puisque c'est l'Ukraine
donc cette péninsule est assoiffée elle
ne peut pas se nourrir être la
logistique ne marche pas donc il faut
construire quelque chose pour
approvisionner cette île et Poutine dit
on va construire un pont ça a coûté
comme disait Emmanuel Macron une blinde
et donc pour lui 19 km c'est le plus
grand pont d'Europe paraît-il et c'est
une cible stratégique parce que si on le
coupe la Crimée n'existe plus tout passe
par là donc les toutes les fournitures
passent par là y compris l'électricité
l'eau tout
et les Ukrainiens quand il y a Poutine a
commencé la guerre le 24 février ils ont
dit ce pont il faudra qu'on la coupe et
à ce moment-là le numéro 2 l'ancien
président de Russie Metz a dit si vous
touchez à ce pont au mois de mai il a
dit je vous promets le jour de jugement
dernier c'est à dire donc c'est
important de t'expliquer à noter les
spectateurs ça veut dire que clairement
il disait si vous touchez à ce pont ils
ont touché à ce problème c'est la
réponse nucléaire parce que Jugement
Dernier Armageddon c'est ça
le pont est touché et donc nous les
spécialistes le matin on commence à se
dire
qu'est-ce qui va se passer aujourd'hui
donc on attend Poutine ne dit rien et
comment ça circulait on fête les
versions qui c'est qui a fait sauter les
ponts parce que les Ukrainiens en fait
ils sont très au sobre ils disent ça on
se réjouit c'est un bon cadeau mais
c'est pas nous enfin il n'assume pas ou
assume un demi mot et donc comment c'est
circuler les trucs et dimanche donc tout
de suite on a des déjà des vidéos de ce
camion qui circule le problème c'est que
ce camion vient de Russie
ce pont est le pont le mieux gardé du
monde paraît-il en fait Poutine le
disait ça c'est le camion on n'est pas
sûr que ce sont les Ukrainiens
c'est venu de Russie d'accord s'ils sont
les Ukrainiens ils sont quand même
géniaux ça veut dire ils sont ils sont
les gens qui sont ce qu'ils sont
capables de pénétrer dans un pont
normalement vous pensez que ce serait
qui alors
pour être qui or on va juste quelques
mots encore et donc il y a deux points
de contrôle à l'entrée des ponts des
deux côtés c'est impossible de rentrer
sans être contrôlé parce que il y a des
rayons X il y a tout un tas de personnes
qui qui vous contrôle il y a des gardes
de la garde nationale qui qui contrôle
il y a le FSB le service de sécurité qui
contrôle comment ce camion est arrivé
sur ce que vous êtes en train de dire
vous êtes en train de nous dire que
c'est quoi ça peut être on peut pas
passer donc
un truc comme ça soit les positions
qui étaient dans la région de Krasnodar
en Russie soit quoi ce sont les Russes
pour avoir un prétexte parce que un
prétexte parce que en fait la question à
la limite tout de suite on allait dire
oh c'est du complotisme parce que vous
voyez pas ce sont les Ukrainiens etc
Poutine à Asie ce sont les Ukrainiens
mais si ce camion pénètre dans le pont
la sécurité est assurée par le service
de sécurité de la Russie donc il a
failli
est-ce que
un petit quiz croyez-vous qu'il y a un
seul militaire ou un seul responsable
des services secrets russes qui auraient
été puni par Poutine suite à ça
bien sûr
personne président du FSB directeur de
facebook pas du tout c'est pas son
boulot directeur de la Garde
Républicaine pas du tout c'est pas son
boulot ministre de la défense c'est ça
il y a
10 personnes il y a 10 personnes qui
sont responsables de la sécurité il y a
plus il y a personne qui a été puni par
Poutine mais ça veut dire quoi c'est
grave ça n'engage que ça n'engage que
serviette bien entendu moi c'est ce que
Sergueï mais ce que vous êtes en train
de nous dire c'est assez incroyable vous
êtes en train de nous dire pour vous il
y a une possibilité parmi les hypothèses
voilà que vous avez avancé que ce soit
peut-être pour vous
Vladimir Poutine qui aurait fait passer
ce camion pour avoir un prétexte
d'utiliser les larmes nucléaires moi je
suis un analyste oui et moi je suis un
expert donc c'est pas ma version je vous
dis les différentes hypothèses je vous
donne des faits je vous donne des faits
et après je vous pose les questions par
rapport à ces faits donc si personne
côté russe n'a pas été puni à qui
profite le crime et donc ce matin on se
réveille et lundi mais même les
Américains disent que sont les
Ukrainiens
la CIA a dit les Ukrainiens disent
beaucoup de choses la CIA a dit que il y
a une taupe au Kremlin est-ce que vous
croyez que la CIA si elle avait un top
une top au Kremlin aller l'annoncer à
Washington Post ou à New yorkems qui est
là une tope Kremlin donc il faut se
méfier aussi de ce qu'on raconte les
Américains
de vos hypothèses moi je peux je me dis
que ça serait quand même curieux que ce
soit ça c'est quand même il y a quand
même trois ou quatre morts hier au
niveau au niveau de pertes humaines il y
a enfin on est en guerre on est en
guerre donc on va dire quasiment pas pas
de pertes humaines parce qu'il y a eu
deux personnes dans un véhicule léger
plus le chauffeur du véhicule il y a
trois personnes qui qui ont été tués
après le pont n'est pas coupé
entièrement ça veut dire qu'il y a une
partie la moitié du pont autoroutier qui
est qui est immobilisé l'autre moitié
fonctionne et le pont ferroviaire pour
fonctionne Poutine hier dimanche 9
octobre fait convoqué le directeur de
des enquêtes judiciaires de Russie et tu
dis qu'est-ce qui se passe et l'autre 48
heures après il dit nous avons tout
trouvé ce sont les ukrainiens et les
pays étrangers qui soutiennent le crâne
parce que nous avons trouvé que ce
camion est passé par la Bulgarie
l'Arménie la Géorgie l'ossetti et puis
après il est arrivé chez nous et donc en
fait Poutine laisse entendre que c'est
un complot mondial pour pour faire ça et
ça lui et donc et en fait il répète hier
devant ce monsieur
là cet artère qui est une
qui est un moyen critique d'existence de
Crimée ce qui est faux
parce que la Crimée depuis le 22 le 24
février il y a des territoires
Ukrainiens à compter qui ont été conquis
par les Russes asapson et donc
actuellement la Crimée contrairement à
ya habitants peut être approvisionné par
la Russie directement donc Poutine après
texte et ce matin qu'est-ce qu'on voit
on voit les frappes sur toute l'Ukraine
juste sur toute l'Ukraine y compris sur
45 habitations rien qu'à Kief 12 musées
elle est où la réponse par rapport à ça
12 on attaque les musées donc les écoles
les universités
en France aussi en France non pas encore
d'accord pas encore mais en Ukraine oui
d'accord parce qu'en fait le problème
c'est que depuis quelques temps Poutine
est accumulé
ça mobilisation ne marche pas et la
proclamé la mobilisation les gens ne
sont même pas équipés vous savez que
elle est actuellement les gens qui sont
mobilisées ils sont obligés de prendre
des crédits pour 5000 euros pour acheter
leur propre équipements quand vous allez
servir dans l'armée c'est vu dans quel
pays du monde du monde où c'est l'armée
qui vous dit on peut pas vous équiper
achetez-vous débrouillez-vous vous-même
et donc quand il est acculé qu'est-ce
qu'il lui reste la violence qu'est-ce
qui lui reste et donc chaque jour
malheureusement depuis 8 mois on se
rapproche on se rapproche cette semaine
ça va être une semaine décisive 2 cette
semaine va être une semaine décisive
cette semaine on va on va voir ce que ça
donne on va voir ce que ça donne on voit
que les frappes intensifient et vous
pensez que ça on va on va voir demain
est-ce qu'ils vont continuer à frapper
on va voir la réponse jésus-chrenia donc
déjà il y a une un tollé général dans le
monde entier il y a aujourd'hui le vote
aussi à l'Assemblée à l'Assemblée
générale des Nations unies pour
condamner Poutine pour l'annexion des
quatre régions qui ont été faites le 30
septembre il y a beaucoup de gens aussi
qui disent voilà que pour l'instant tout
le monde dit bien sûr que ce sont les
Ukrainiens les différents services
secrets d'ici il y a les services
secrets français et la France ne sait
pas prononcé mais ils disent que sont
les chrétiens donc c'est vrai que voilà
que je le redis voilà ça engage que
sergueil il a exposé les différentes
hypothèses dont celle-ci avant de vous
libérer Sergueï il y a une autre image
forte qui a fait énormément parler ce
matin c'est le live ce live de la BBC
dans lequel le journaliste se fait
surprendre par les bombardements
regardez
[Musique]
voilà c'est vrai que je voulais vous
montrer ça merci Serguey en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous de vous expliquer
la situation vous revenez assez vite et
voilà il y a beaucoup de gens qui
réagissent sur votre dernier hypothèse
et qui disent que vous êtes vous êtes
fous vous le dites
de ça voilà bah voilà voilà vous dites
vous dites peut-être moi je pense c'est
c'est quand même ce serait quand même
bizarre voilà mais bon après voilà c'est
réglé non